[Music]
and welcome to Hannity tonight and aom
from the mosque that was frequented by
the man charged with the beheading of
that woman in Moore Oklahoma went on the
offensive in a sermon on Friday
targeting a former mosque attendee who
had revealed some well not so flattering
details about the mosque in an interview
last week on Fox News this is what the
Imam
said I could find for that one person
who did not identify himself on Fox news
talking about this very mjid I could
find a thousand people who would
rebuttle his his testimony now we have
extended an invitation to the Imam that
you just heard from to join us on this
program but he declined and the
invitation by the way remains open
joining me now though is a former member
of this mosque who was berated in that
sermon nor is a well who has asked us
that we conceal our identity for his
safety and also joining us is the
director of jihad watch Robert Spencer
guys good to see you both and Robert I
know you broke the story first good to
see you thank you for being with us nor
let me start with you what was said
behind closed doors at this mosque what
was going on behind the scenes do you
believe that the person responsible for
the beheading could have been influenced
by some of the teachings in that
mosque
absolutely things that were taught
behind closed doors um were things like
the choice that non-believers are to be
offered by Muslims to either convert
live under Islamic uh domination and be
in sub submission to the Islamic State
or to be fought against which is Jihad
Jihad for the sake of Allah other things
that were mentioned were open support at
least among Muslims fellow Muslims for
suicide bombings in Israel and it was
explained to me that this was the only
weapon that the Palestinians had
and that
therefore we do condone them but we will
not talk about it with the media and I
was advised not to speak with the media
on it because they would not understand
did you take the the comments this
weekend by the Imam as a threat to you
and your
family I take everything that they say
as a threat to me so um I want to go
into more detail you're saying that
behind closed doors when you were alone
with fellow members of this mosque that
their ideology is pretty much convert or
die absolutely this is shown in the
simple teachings of Islam that you
anyone can find like among sahim Muslim
where it specifically says that the
non-believers are to be offered three
choices to convert live under Islamic
Rule and pay the gizia or pole tax or to
be fought
against basically you're saying the
exact things that the Christians in in
mosul will were
told convert pay the tax or
die absolutely I was told that this
ultimately is going to be the choice
that are going to be offered to all
non-muslims around the world including
in the United States tell me about the
the the level of media sophistication in
other words is this something they would
say openly would they only say among
members that they trusted it doesn't
sound like the type of thing that that
an Imam on on during a service would go
up there and say was this done in in
private yes these things were not openly
said when they know that um Outsiders
are among them like the media and most
of the time these things were not said
in any kind of sermon there were things
approaching that said in a few sermons
The Imam now Imad and chassi once stated
in a sermon that the Israelis were
trying to collapse Al oxa mosque in
Jerusalem by digging tunnels underneath
it so there is a high level of hatred of
Israel and but most of the things that
were said to me were always said when it
was safe to say them which was among
other Muslims well tell me things that
might have been said about 9/11 about uh
Jihad about infidels about you mentioned
Jews maybe about Christians uh or maybe
about Isis for example or Al-Qaeda do
you remember any specific things that
were said about any of those things
there was an instance when I was sitting
with two members of the mosque as I
mentioned um and they stated to me the
when the subject of AMA Bin Laden came
up that if he showed up at their door
they would invite him in and would
protect him because he's a brother in
Islam and we must protect him from those
who don't
believe other instances as I yeah go
ahead go ahead no go keep other
instances other instances were as I said
the support for suicide bombings in
Israel um I spoke with another
individual later after I had left Islam
but went back at the request of law
enforcement um about the acts of
terrorism that were going on in
Iraq and he stated to me that this is
their country and they can do what they
like to any of the Crusaders that come
in to try to oos their will on the on
the Muslim people do you have any doubt
that Elon Anton Nolan was influenced by
what went on in this mosque and that
this could have encouraged him do you
believe that would have that that could
have happened to somebody at a mosque
like this absolutely when you promote
the the true pure teachings of Islam as
practiced by the prophet
Muhammad um you can't take it any other
way unless you're willfully ignorant or
you're lying yeah Robert Spencer let me
let me let me bring you into uh all of
this cuz you you obviously broke this
story and I give you a lot of credit for
doing this um I I know that the
president is saying they they actually
sent a representative from the White
House to this mosque to praise them uh
this weekend and and gave a letter that
was apparently read from the president I
guess praising this mosque um they just
had the the the funeral of the woman on
Friday now they claim it was it was
related to the the tornado that impacted
the area going back a couple of years or
last year um do you believe
that no I think that it's directly
related to the beheading it's related to
the fact that the Obama Administration
has completely bought into the line
spread by groups like the Hamas Council
on American Islamic relations and others
that anytime there's a Jihad attack or a
Jihad plot the real victims are Muslims
and it's really a very clever Ploy that
they use to deflect attention away from
Jihad activity I mean see the president
sends a letter A thank you letter to
this mosque now why now and why not call
for an investigation into what's being
taught in the mosque and how much Nolan
jaim Israel the beheader was influenced
by what he learned in this mosque you
you raised some great Point 80% of
mosques in the United States have been
shown in four separate and independent
studies since 1998 to be teaching hatred
of Jews and Christians and the necessity
ultimately to replace the Constitution
with his this man was talking is
completely plausible completely in line
with what we know this man wanted to
convert his co-workers this man was
using Islamic uh phrases as he beheaded
this woman we look at this beheaders
Facebook page it's like a who's who of
of radical islamist and their techniques
I I thought you raised some good
questions is there going to be an
investigation of the mosque what about
the Imam is he going to be questioned
did he know the beheader you rais other
questions uh you know are there any
emails or phone calls between the Imam
and and the person responsing Nolan in
this case for this beheading an
examination of what the teachings are
here um I think all of those would have
be appropriate are you saying that none
of that is
happening that's to the best of my
knowledge Sean at this point nothing's
been done nobody's looked at the
beheaders phone records nobody's looked
at his emails nobody's checked if he's
had any contact with people in the
mosque or other people in other groups
it's just been a a complete take your
word for it situation the mosque says oh
this guy didn't learn any of that here
and the FED say okay and turn away
because of course they're committed as a
matter of policy to ignoring and
denying any Jihad agitation or prizing
going on in mosqu in the United States
they're committed to denying that and so
they don't want to see evidence of it
even when it's right on their doorstep
gentlemen thank you both for being with
us very informative we're going to
continue to follow this Robert thank you
appreciate it Nora thank you appreciate
you being here